that's not the plan
she she's just a territorial but she's
she's understanding like she's just more
mature you know it's not like she's not
gonna she's not gonna I mean
she's not gonna compromise okay okay
she's not gonna compromise herself to
get even with me or yeah to prove a
point to me yeah like she's more like
just saying you know so what you're
saying is she would not steal your Range
Rover and drive it across the country
after writing stuff with her own blood
on the wall hell no okay that's like I'm
just curious when you saw that that
happened what is going through your mind
are you like my kids are never going
over there again
it was the craziest [__] ever
um honestly I don't know I thought it
was kind of weird
um just because it was like the day
before Valentine's Day so it kind of
seemed like is everyone okay I don't
know I just don't really pay no mind to
that you know [__] attention I just
don't really like give in to like the
like woes me type of situations like I
just don't care so I kind of just treat
it like a it's another one of them
I mean I just don't I'm just not gonna
harp on stuff that's like one one it's
out of my control too I don't give a
[__] and three has nothing to do with me
like I don't know I'm just don't Jaden
I'm curious
um obviously we know you as
his baby mama right
I mean obviously I'm sure he takes care
of his kids but prior to you being uh
starting this musical career are you do
you have like a gig do you work like
what's your what do you what what are
you doing I had to work one day no
um I used to well before he did this I
used to work but yeah that's real tell
them no he ever since he when he got on
and I had to work which is you know God
said that I I don't know I'm not
ungrateful I'm not ungrateful but I'm
doing it for her to you so you've never
had to work yeah since he blew up now oh
wow not a second not a day I don't have
to there were certain things I did just
because I was like yeah I want to do
that or I want to start this or I want
to start that I did a skin thing
um that was I was doing a whole like
skin care uh treatment room before I had
my second kid okay but after that one I
kind of was like oh my God two kids is
crazy
that was something I kind of like yeah
like he wanted me to find something that
I like to do right right I don't mind
paying for you but like what do you want
to do
[Music]
I wanted to be a boss or something and I
and I just knew that if I couldn't be a
boss or something until like I was
skilled in it myself you know what I
mean because how am I going to tell
someone to do something and I don't know
how to do it I went to esthetician
school I funded a paper fire yeah and
then so you can do uh some facial I can
wax I can do all that but her own parlor
she was hiring people I [__] with it
but I don't think it was like her dry I
think it was just I wanted to be a boss
but I wanted like then I wanted someone
to like micromanage that like tell me
what everyone's doing you know what I
mean I wanted to get to that point and I
was almost to that point and then I got
pregnant again and then I had the second
baby and it kind of it definitely slowed
me down you know
um because I just I couldn't keep up
keep up with everything like and it was
it was about like 30 minutes away from
where I was at so I was just like
who can keep up with me and then whoever
was there ended up doing some weird [__]
to me I had to kick her out